we're asked how many toothpicks will be
needed to form the 50th figure in this
sequence and they've drawn the first
four figures in the sequences the first
the second the third now let's see
what's happening here so in this first
figure we have this nice little little
house that they made out of toothpicks
and it has one
two three four five
six toothpicks so the first the first
figure in our sequence has six
toothpicks now what happens in the
second figure here well it looks just
like our first figure we have our one
two three four five six toothpicks but
then they add some toothpicks looks like
they added one
two
three four
five toothpicks so it's six plus five or
11 toothpicks so let me write this down
it is the six toothpicks plus five more
plus five more which is equal to which
is equal to 11 toothpicks and then we go
to the third figure it looks just like
the second figure so it has the 11
toothpicks so the 11 toothpicks are the
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 just like the second figure
and then they add some more
they add some more they add one two
three four five so it looks like every
time when you draw a part of another
house because it can kind of share a
wall with the previous house or share a
toothpick with the previous set of
houses you add five toothpicks so for
the third term in our sequence we had 11
and when we had our second term or i
guess our two houses and then we add
five more
we add five more so to our fiftieth term
so eleven plus five is going to be
eleven plus five is going to be sixteen
and then for the fourth term it's going
to be 16 plus 5. so it's going to be 16
plus 5 which is equal to
21. now there's a couple of ways to
think about it you can think about
however many more you are than one so
let's say you are in the nth term of the
sequence
if you are in the nth
term
however more you are than one so if
you're the nth term you're going to be n
minus one more than one
if that is confusing
we'll we'll do it with real numbers so
it gets a little bit more tangible so
the nth term
you are
n minus 1
more
or greater than i'll just say more
than
ones for example if n is two you are one
more than one if n is three you are
three minus one which is two more than
one so however much more you are than
one you multiply that by 5. we're 2 more
than 1 so we add 10 to the number of
toothpicks we have here we're 3 more
than 1 here so we add 15 to the number
of toothpicks we have there so you could
say that for the nth term
the number of toothpicks
number of toothpicks
number of toothpicks
is equal to the number you're more than
one so n minus one
n minus 1
times 5 that's how much you're going to
add above and beyond the amount of
toothpicks in just the first sequence so
times 5
n minus 1 times 5 plus the number of
toothpicks that you just have with in
the first sequence or just this one
house and we already counted that plus
six so that's one way to think about it
and if this looks complicated you just
say well look if i put a four here i'm
three more than one so four minus one is
three so that'll be 3 times 5 which is
15 and then you add the number of
toothpicks in 1 and you get 6. now
another way and many of y'all might find
this easier to think about
is
even in 1 you could imagine you could
imagine a term here well let me do it
this way
you could imagine a term here that they
didn't draw you could imagine a zeroth
term so let me just draw it here imagine
a zeroth term and the zeroth term would
just be kind of a left wall of the house
or in this case the left toothpick of a
house and then the first one you're
adding five toothpicks to that and the
second one you're adding five toothpicks
to that and when you think about it this
way it actually becomes a little simpler
to think in terms of n here you could
say well the nth term let me do this in
a different color
you could say that the nth term
the nth term
is going to have is going to have or
maybe we should say number of toothpicks
in
an nth figure
number
of toothpicks
toothpicks
in
nth
figure
is going to be equal to
one so in the zeroth figure which i just
made up you have at least one toothpick
and then
however whatever term in the sequences
are you multiply that times five and you
add that to the number of toothpicks in
the zeroth figure so it's one
plus 5
times n which is actually a simpler way
to think about it the first figure is
going to be that 1 in the 0th figure
plus 5 6 toothpicks even the 0th figure
it works out if you put a 0 here 0 plus
1 is 1. if you put the fourth figure
here 5 times 4 is 20 plus 1 is 21. now
let's answer their question we need to
figure out the toothpicks in the 50th
figure in the sequence well we just put
50 for n here so for the 50th figure
50th
figure
we could use either formula we have 1
plus 5 times 50 5 times 50. 5 times 50
is 250 plus 1 is equal to 251. and now i
said you could use either formula
because they should reduce to each other
if we did our math right or if we
deduced properly so this one up here
let's just verify that's the same thing
as this over here if we've if we
if we multiply five times n minus one we
get five n
minus five
right we just distributed the five and
then we have that plus six
plus six negative 5 plus 6 is
plus 1
plus 1 so it's 5 n plus 1 or 1 plus 5 n
either way your 250 your 50th figure is
going to have 251 toothpicks in it